[Musique]
et la parole est à notre collègue jean
pierre sueur pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
merci monsieur le président madame le
garde des sceaux
vous avez déclaré que votre seule
boussole était l'intérêt du justiciable
et l'intérêt général je crains que vous
ayez perdu égaré la boussole
en effet nous avons appris l'existence
d'un document issu de votre cabinet kim
est scandaleusement en cause la
neutralité du service public dont vous
avez la charge
madame le garde des sceaux étiez vous au
courant de l'existence de ce document
deuxièmement avez vous demandé qu'il
soit établi
troisièmement puisqu'il a été
communiquée au cabinet du premier
ministre
avez vous reçu instruction du premier
ministre de faire établir ce document
quatrièmement avez-vous diligenté une
enquête pour savoir dans quelles
conditions ce document a été établi et
qu'il a établie cinquièmement quelles
sanctions
prévoyez vous de mettre en oeuvre à
l'égard de ceux qui sont responsables de
cette atteinte intolérable à la
neutralité de votre service public
pour vous répondre la parole à madame la
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
garde des sceaux
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean pierre sueur
oui je le revendique ma boussole c'est
l'intérêt du justiciable
et c'est l'intérêt général je le dis
très clairement et d'ailleurs dans
l'ensemble des décisions qui sont prises
pour faire évoluer les juridictions
qu'il s'agisse de la fusion entre
tribunal de grande instance et tribunal
d'instance qui au 1er janvier prochain
va donner naissance au tribunal
judiciaire
qu'il s'agisse de l'éventuelle
répartition des contentieux spécialisés
entre juridictions
tout cela repose sur une procédure qui a
été clairement établie dans la loi de
réforme de la justice qui a été votée
par le parlement le 23 mars dernier et
tout cela repose sur des critères
objectifs qui sont très clairs et qu'ils
sont très transparent tout cela repose
également sur une analyse contextuelle
et donc politique d'une situation
politique au sens et je le revendique de
la prise en compte de critères
socio-économiques de la prise en compte
de critères démographiques de la prise
en compte de critères géographiques
c'est cela qui forment la police c'est à
dire la vie de la cité
tout ce qui est clairement tout ce qui
est partisan c'est un point que je
réfute totalement
et je dis clairement devant vous que
aucun élément partisans ne préside à
l'élaboration des décisions publiques
c'est ce que je tenais à réaffirmer
devant vous le chercheur
madame la ministre vous n'avez répondu
ni à ma première question ni à la
seconde ni à la troisième ligne est la
quatrième nuit à la 5e
vous croyez que cet habile ce n'est pas
du tout habile c'est consternant c'est
consternant parce que reste cette
atteinte intolérable à la neutralité du
service public de la justice
ce qui n'est quand même pas rien dans
notre république et dont vous avez la
charge personnellement la parole est à
votre collègue antoine lefèvre pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à la garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice et à la suite du président
sueur je vais vous parler de votre
boussole voilà une semaine que des
révélations concernant un email de votre
ministère au cabinet du premier ministre
plonge le monde judiciaire et les élus
dans le désarroi et la consternation
ce document destiné à élaborer une
stratégie à adopter pour la suppression
de certains cabinets d'instruction
entend cibler opérer un tri en fonction
des scores obtenus par le parti
présidentiel et selon la couleur
politique des élus des villes concernées
les villes potentiellement visés par
ladite réforme se transforme en effet en
véritable cible électorale
ce procédé est profondément choquant
comment voulez vous justifiez dans
l'organisation territoriale de notre
justice une sanction envers les
territoires qu'ils ne voteraient pas
comme il faut notre l'intrusion de
considérations politiciennes dans
l'ordre du judiciaire est un manquement
grave à la stricte séparation des
pouvoirs et aux fondements de la
démocratie
tous les services de l'état doivent
naturellement agir dans la partialité
mais s'il ya bien un qui doit être le
plus simple irréprochable tous c'est
bien évidemment la justice alors madame
la ministre moi je n'ai qu'une seule
question et non pas quatre elle est
simple j'espère obtenir une réponse
pouvez-vous nous assurer de la mise en
place d'une procédure parfaitement
transparente avec des critères
réellement objectifs dans leur
groupement territorial des pôles de
l'instruction
madame la garde des sceaux madame bello
v pour répondre merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs lefebvre la réponse est très
claire c'est oui oui je peux vous
assurer d'une procédure parfaitement
rigoureuse sur des critères objectifs
clairs
des critères qui sont partagés et en
plus ce également construit avec une
procédure qui est écrite dans la loi qui
a été adoptée par le parlement
les critères ils sont simples il
constitue pour le pôle de l'instruction
pour les juges d'instruction il s'agit
du nombre de dossiers traités sur cinq
ans ce qui nous donne une moyenne et ces
critères-là objectifs clairs sont
pondérées par la prise en compte d'une
réalité géographique de distance des
territoires d'une réalité socio
économique d'une réalité territoriale et
cela aussi est écrit dans la loi car en
effet dans le texte de la loi
je vous rappelle qu'il est expressément
prévu que les conseils de juridiction
composée des magistrats des avocats et
des élus seront systématiquement
consulté c'est écrit dans le texte de la
loi
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à des études
qui sont des études préliminaires et il
est évident que c'est un processus qui
est en cours
le mail auquel vous faites allusion j'ai
eu l'occasion de dire à propos de
l'écriture de ce document qui est un
mail de cabinet à cabinet j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que l'écriture était
maladroite et inadaptées car elle ne
correspond en aucune manière en aucune
manière aux principes éthiques qui
doivent guider l'élaboration de la
décision publique en matière
d'organisation des juridictions il va de
soi que seul compte l'intérêt général la
réalité des territoires des principes et
une procédure claire c'est ce qui est
écrit dans la loi
c'est ce que nous faisons et nous seront
comptables devant vous des résultats qui
seront obtenus sur le fleuve
bien madame la garde des sceaux même si
vous tenté de minimiser la portée réelle
de cette affaire vos éléments de réponse
nous retire en rien le profond malaise
qui secoue la magistrature et les
territoires car vos critères madame la
garde des sceaux sont bien des critères
politiciens notamment lorsque cette note
évoque la couleur politique des élus il
y a un an sur ma proposition de
rapporteur spécial de la mission justice
le sénat avait décidé de valider des
crédits de votre ministère vous avez
témoigné ce midi au cours de votre
audition votre reconnaissance au sénat
pour l'augmentation de ces crédits
conscient de l'impératif de
modernisation de votre administration le
sénat nous a soutenus car nous faisions
confiance pour agir dans l'intérêt du
justiciable
en agissant de façon partisane vous avez
trahi cette confiance c'est aussi pour
cette raison que notre commission des
finances qui s'est réuni hier a décidé
de ne pas approuver vos crédits pour
2020 aujourd'hui fort recul certaine
amertume nous constatons que ce lien de
confiance est rompu par une politisation
déplacer et indigne d'une justice du 21e
siècle
merci la parole est à notre collègue
gérard longuet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
oui merci oui merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adressait à
mesure le premier ministre parce qu'il
s'agit d'abord et avant tout d'une
question de cohérence gouvernementale
dont le premier ministre a normalement
la responsabilité madame sylviane
agacinski a été privé par la présidente
de l'université bordeaux montaigne du
droit de s'exprimer
ça ce sont les fêtes les réactions
gouvernementales et surprenante
madame marlène ce qui a pas à sauver
l'honneur du gouvernement en exprimant
publiquement son désaccord qu'il en soit
donné acte madame le ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur directement
concerné puisqu'il s'agissait de
l'université a répondu d'une façon assez
ambigu à notre excellent collègue
charles de la verpillière juristes
éminents qu'un forum serait organisée je
souhaite pour elle que ce forum soit
acceptée par les minorités
il y avait précédemment refusé madame
agacinscki mais vos autres ministres
auraient pu eux aussi s'exprimer
monsieur castaner lorsque des agents du
service public sont privés d'une
formation organisée par la sorbonne un
panthéon formation que mohamed sifaoui
qui est bien connu avait organisé pour
les sensibiliser sur le terrain de la
radicalisation de la même façon je crois
qu'il ya un ministre de la culture je ne
l'ait pas entendu se désolidariser de
ceux qui ont des programmes et monsieur
charb monsieur charbonnier assassiné
avec ses camarades de charlie hebdo et
qui est privé à titre posthume du droit
de s'exprimer tant à l'université que
dans des théâtres municipaux
nous avons une situation où le ministre
de la culture ou de demain va être
confronté à des journalistes qui n'ont
plus le droit de s'exprimer en direct
c'est le cas d'eric zemmour il y à une
pétition de journalistes et nous avons à
cet instant la certitude que vous ne
respectez vous ne respecter le droit de
parler que si et seulement si les
minorités turbulente vous en donne
l'autorisation pour vous répondre
quand vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur blanc caire merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président longuet le problème que vous
soulevez est un problème bien réel
l'université est né en europe sur le
principe de la liberté de conscience et
sur la liberté d'expression
c'est d'une certaine façon elle qui
porte notre civilisation depuis le début
et l'humanisme qui la caractérise et à
la base de cet humanisme il y à la
liberté d'expression ce qui s'est passé
à bordeaux et ce qui c à paris est passé
à paris est absolument inacceptable
c'est inacceptable et cela doit nous
alerter parce que ce n'est pas un
mouvement spécifiquement français c'est
une sorte de nouveau maccarthysme qui
fait que l'on veut s'attaquer à la
liberté d'expression
chacun sait que ce que veut défendre un
magasin ce qui ne correspond pas aux
positions du gouvernement mais c'est
notre honneur et c'est ce qu'a fait en
effet mal en ce cas pas que de dire que
bien entendu comme le disait voltaire
nous sommes non seulement nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec elle que nous serions
prêts à nous battre pour qu'elle puisse
s'exprimer
et il est triste de voir qu on enrôle la
jeunesse parfois dans des manifestations
d'intolérance qui consiste à empêcher
qu'une manifestation de ce genre aient
lieu de la même façon il ya une
autonomie des universités qui est à la
base de cette tradition universitaire et
donc les présidents d'université prenne
des décisions
en vertu de cette autonomie des
universités n'appartient pas à la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
que je au nom de quel de qui je parle et
je vous prie d'excuser son absence
puisqu'elle est un congrès sur
l'intelligence artificielle avec le
président de la république ne lui
appartient pas de prendre directement
ses décisions cela relève des présidents
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il est
temps en effet dans notre rôle et c'est
ce que nous faisons l'ensemble du
gouvernement de condamner ce qui s'est
passé dans les deux cas s'agissant de ce
qui s'est passé à paris un à la sorbonne
il est tout à fait anormal d'être dans
la situation d'intimidation d'une
personnalité monsieur mohamed sifaoui
qui en effet se bat courageusement
contre la radicalisation et qui avait
monté une un séminaire convenu en plus
avec le cfcm en aucun cas susceptible
donc d'être considérés comme extrémistes
d'une quelconque façon
ce nous le déplorons nous déplorons ce
report est bien entendu nous tous nous
suivrons cette affaire parce qu'il n'est
pas normal d'en rester là
il ne peut pas y avoir ainsi une
victoire de ceux qui sont les ennemis de
la liberté
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente catherine morin desailly pour
le groupe de l'union centriste et le
président la question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
elle prolonge une certaine manière celle
de gérard longuet il y a eu la lune à
sion comme il l'a dit par l'université
paris 1 panthéon sorbonne de la
formation sur la prévention de la
radicalisation qui devait être distancé
fin novembre par l'écrivain et
journaliste mohamed sifaoui en raison
d'un climat de pression et de menaces
notre groupe s'est également inquiété de
l'annulation de conférence le 24 octobre
dernier par l'université bordeaux
montait ou la philosophe sylviane
agacinski devait s'exprimer sur le site
l'être humain à l'époque de sa
reproductibilité technique dans le cadre
de huit conférences destinées je cite
toujours
promouvoir un usage critique des savoirs
qui permettent de penser ensemble notre
monde et saison ge
que se passe-t-il donc à l'université
cette dernière manifestation a été
annulée en raison je suis les
organisateurs de menaces violentes
émanant de groupes opposés aux positions
de la philosophe sur les sujets
actuellement en débat de la pma et de la
gpa le débat viendra bientôt sénat pour
lequel en avance auditionné tous les
points de vue ce qui reste encore une
des meilleures façons de se construire
un jugement
mais comment en sommes nous arrivés là
des faits choquants pour nombre de nos
concitoyens qui s'apparente réellement
des prises d'otages par des activistes
identifié et qui font désormais rennais
ici et là une forme de terreur
intellectuelle
monsieur le ministre mes questions sont
assez précise trouvez vous normal que
les présidents d'université concernés
sans doute eux mêmes menacés et était
obligé de céder aux injonctions de ces
individus mais pourriez-vous de surtout
nous dire du coup quelles sont les
mesures très concrètes que vous comptez
prendre pour garantir au sein de ces
établissements la liberté d'expression
et les conditions de débats d'idées
serein on veut répondre la parole
automobilistes de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice seulement un desailly
en effet votre question prolonge celle
du président longuet il me permet donc
de prolonger ma réponse d'abord tout
comme vous évidemment frédéric vidal et
l'ensemble du gouvernement se
manifestent leur désapprobation de ce
type d'actions extrémistes qui vont
contre la liberté de conscience et
contre la liberté d'expression c'est
tout à fait contraire à toutes les
traditions universitaires
je vous à dire qu'il n'ya aucun laxisme
de la part du gouvernement par rapport à
ce type de manifestation si on prend un
incident du même type qui a eu lieu il
ya quelques semaines qui est l
interruption d'une pièce de théâtre les
suppliantes d'eschyle qui ne correspond
pas que je sache non plus à quelque
chose d'inacceptable
en quoi que ce soit eh bien
l'interruption de cette pièce de théâtre
était évidemment totalement scandaleuse
et bien la ministre en compagnie du
ministre de la culture franck riester
ont assisté pour bien montrer leur
désapprobation à la représentation de
cette pièce qui a eu lieu quelques temps
plus tard parfois c'est nécessairement
avec un temps de retard que la réaction
peut se passer parce que les choses se
passent rapidement et dans le cadre de
l'autonomie des universités dans les
deux cas que vous avez cités c'est à
dire bordeaux et paris il s'agit de deux
cas différents la ministre bien entendu
suit ces deux cas dans le cadre pas rien
la formation aura bel et bien lieu
simplement il est en effet normal de
s'interroger sur le fait une sorte de
censure sur une personne qui était prévu
et la pense que c'est l'ensemble de la
société civile de s'interroger sur ce
que l'université fait dans ces cas là
dans le cas de bordeaux
une nouvelle conférence sera organisée
la ministre weil elle-même
il est probable qu'elles qu'elles sont
en assurera personnellement avec la
présidente de l'université qui a eu
comme premier souci le maintien de
l'ordre public
il faut bien comprendre que les
présidents d'université sont dans cette
situation
mais cette situation en effet renvoie au
problème que vous avez mentionné c'est à
dire il y a des gens qui se mettent en
situation de menace en situation de
rupture de l'ordre public et ça n'est
pas acceptable et nous ne l'accepterons
pas madame la présidente
voilà donc plus le droit de débattre
peut-être bientôt plus droit de
réfléchir cette montée de l'intolérance
mes chers collègues est extrêmement
préoccupante surtout si elle doit aller
parfois jusqu'à des menaces physiques
peut être parfois plus en tout cas
monsieur mise en conviendrez
l'université doit vraiment rester le
lieu de la dialectique et de la
controverse du l'accès au savoir et à la
formation
nous comptons sur vous et à madame la
ministre vidal pour que cela reste ainsi
je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente bien la
parole est à notre collègue philippe
pemezec pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
le président bonjour mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux très
haut commissaire à la réforme des
retraites
vous travaillez depuis deux ans monsieur
le ministre à une réforme des retraites
et la semaine dernière encore vous avez
été désavoué par le président de la
république
quant au modèle que vous proposez vous
aviez annoncé un aboutissement de la
réforme avant les municipales puis après
les municipales ce qui est plus sage
puis maintenant ça semble repoussée aux
calendes grecques
vous nous avez proposé de passer d'un
système de répartition un système de
points vous avez annoncé la fin des
régimes spéciaux mais on apprend par la
presse que ça tangue au sein du
gouvernement
vous avez dit vous même que l'option
d'une réforme de régimes spéciaux pour
les nouveaux entrants n'était pas votre
tasse de thé elle était celle du
président en vérité une seule chose
semble sûre c'est que vous avez fait le
choix de la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
des retraités puisque les pensions ne
seront pas rêver la risée en 2020 alors
monsieur le ministre croit que le temps
le temps est venu de tomber les masques
de regarder les français dans les yeux
de leur dire la vérité sans en même
temps permanent sans en même temps en
permanence ménager la chèvre et le chou
peut-être craignez vous de revivre les
grèves de 95
j'ai donc deux question êtes vous prêt à
proposer la suppression est immédiat des
régimes spéciaux l'alignement des
régimes du public sur ceux du privé sans
décaler la réforme
quitte à introduire un peu de
progressivité dans cette réforme
deuxièmement et vous prêt à reconnaître
que notre système de répartition ne peut
être maintenue que si il y à un
allongement de la durée de cotisation du
fait simplement de l'espérance de vie
qui s'allonge et du ratio qui s'aggrave
en permanence entre bénéficiaires et
cotisants
merci monsieur liste pour vous répondre
à la parole le haut-commissaire aux
retraites délégué auprès de la ministre
de la solidarité monsieur de le voir
vous avez la parole c'est le président
monsieur le sénateur philippe merci de
de me demander de préciser
ce qui est intéressant et ça ne vous a
pas échappé que depuis deux ans
l'élaboration du rapport est resté
strictement dans le même cap mettre en
place un système universel des retraites
avec des principes extrêmement claire
mêmes règles pour tous carrière
identique cotisations identique retraite
identique un régime universel qui a pour
but de supprimer la totalité des régimes
spéciaux
cet écrit en acceptant quelques
dérogations et spécificités attendait
n'allait pas si vite que ça parce que
certaines demandes de spécificités sont
celles que vous soutenez je pense
notamment aux militaires je pense
notamment aux fonctions régaliennes
mais je pense aussi aux indépendants aux
commerçants dont l'application stricte
de ces règles créerait créerait un
déséquilibre économique donc le voit
bien que les choses sont extrêmement
claires la seconde
la seconde c'est que le calendrier a été
très clairement fixé par le premier
ministre lors du conseil économique
social et environnemental et nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec 350 réunions avec
l'ensemble des ministres concernés en
train de regarder très concrètement
comment le ce principe universel auquel
notre société soutient nos concitoyens
veulent les mêmes règles pour tous
veulent des règles d'équité veulent que
leur retraite sur calculé comme celles
de leurs voisins et ils veulent en même
temps qu'on regarde très concrètement
quelles sont les conséquences catégories
professionnelles par catégorie
professionnelle 350 réunions sont
programmées et en même temps nous
ouvrons un certain nombre de débats
je voudrais me permets de vous corriger
nous ne supprimons pas la répartition
par un point puisque le fait d'élever à
3 plafond c'est le niveau de répartition
le plus élevé des pays développés et
c'est là notre coeur une solidarité
intergénérationnelle à laquelle je sais
vous êtes profondément attaché
la parole est au président thani mohamed
soilihi pour le groupe la république en
marche monsieur le président
depuis lundi 200 cheminots du
technicentre de châtillon ont également
cessé le travail pour protester contre
la remise en cause de 12 journées de
repos compensatoire projet qui a depuis
lors été retiré la méthode a été
contestée car ce mouvement social
inopiné qui a débuté en pleine période
de vacances scolaire provoque
d'importantes perturbations et la colère
de millions d'usagers
en effet si faire grève est un droit que
personne ne conteste
il doit néanmoins s'exercer dans le
respect de certaines règles permettant à
la fois aux cheminots d'exprimer leurs
revendications mais également de limiter
la gêne occasionnée pour les usagers en
les prévenant notamment
pouvez vous nous indiquer quelles sont
les mesures prises pour un dialogue
social de qualité
je vous remercie pour vos répondre la
parole et au secrétaire d'état en charge
des transports
ses jambes at-il djebbari monsieur
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
monsieur le sénateur vous l'avez dit la
sncf connaît des transformations
profondes transformations de
l'entreprise elle-même au 1er janvier
évolution des métiers ouverture à la
concurrence et ses transformations
peuvent être source d'inquiétude pour
les cheminots dès lors il est essentiel
qu'un dialogue social de qualité
puissent s'y déployer et je fais toute
confiance à jean pierre farandou qui
prendra ses fonctions après demain pour
impulser une nouvelle dynamique au plus
près des territoires au plus près des
préoccupations des cheminots pour la
réforme des retraites que vous n'avez
pas cité mais qui fait l'objet de
discussions avec ses syndiqués
actuellement je les recevrai jeudi c'est
à dire demain avec jean paul delevoye
pour évoquer les modalités de transition
vers le régime universel pour autant et
vous l'avez dit force est de constater
que les mouvements des dernières
semaines n'ont pas respecté ni la lettre
ni l'esprit de la loi de 2007 sur les
services publics et ce au détriment de
très nombreux usagers et voyageurs et
clients de la sncf
il revient à la sncf nous l'avons dit
le premier ministre a été clair sur le
sujet de prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent pour les agents qui
n'auraient pas respecté le cadre posé
par la loi
et s'agissant du technicien entre de
châtillon le motif même de la grève est
aujourd'hui invalide et dans la mesure
où le projet de réorganisation qui avait
été proposé a été retirés depuis par la
directrice régionale dès lors les
demandes de primes n'ont pas de
justification de même que les jours de
grève ne seront pas payés c'est en tout
cas la position réitérée de l'entreprise
et la position du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président et la parole
est à notre collègue jean françois
husson pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole vous chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
dure semaine pour les champions
autoproclamés de l'écologie jeudi la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
condamne la france aux manquements pour
avoir dépassé ces seuils limites de
dioxyde de carbone de manière
systématique et répétée
après dix années de procédure le même
jour votre ministère publié un rapport
accablant publions les mauvais résultats
de la france en matière d'émissions de
co2 de dégradation de la biodiversité ou
de la qualité des eaux souterraines ses
faiblesses chroniques en matière
environnementale sont à rapprocher de
l'échec violent de votre politique
fiscale privilégions une écologie
punitive ayant mis le pays en très
grande tension l'an passé à la suite
d'une hausse brutale non concertée et
confiscatoires de la taxe carbone
dans le contexte de changement
climatique actuel et sur la base de ces
mauvais résultats et alors comme un peu
plus de deux ans trois ministres déjà
été en charge de l'écologie allez vous
mener une politique distributive ou bien
mettre vos pas dans ceux de messieurs
hulot et de rugy merci
bon ben on répond de la parole et aux
secrétaires victoire on cherche des
transports merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
messieurs les sénateurs
je vous prie d'abord excusé là l'après
de l'absence d'elisabeth bornes qui est
actuellement en déplacement pour l'après
midi le sénateur le gouvernement a pris
acte de l'arrêt du 24 octobre de la cour
de justice de l'union européenne relatif
au non respect des normes de qualité de
l'air pour le dioxyde d'azoté mais vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que ce problème
ne date pas d'hier et je rappelle tout
de même que sur la période 2010 2018 les
émissions d'oxydés d'azoté baissé de 54
% et que le nombre d'agglomérations
concernés par les déplacements de la
valeur limite a été diminuée de moitié
cela n'est pas suffisant et je veux vous
assurer de la totale mobilisation du
gouvernement sur le sujet cela passe par
une mesure en tout cas une série de
mesures structurantes déjà engagées
telles que l'accompagnement au
renouvellement du parc automobile le
développement de bornes électriques
l'aide aux particuliers pour renouveler
les appareils de chauffage ou encore
l'accompagnement financier des
collectivités au travers des dispositifs
de l'ademe des nouvelles actions sont
inscrites au travers notamment de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités dont nous
avons eu à débattre collectivement ces
derniers mois ces actions portent sur le
déploiement des zones à faibles
émissions dans les métropoles qui sera
obligatoire dès lors que les
collectivités dépasse régulièrement les
valeurs-limites action qui passe aussi
par la mise en oeuvre du plan vélo qui
comme vous savez doublera triplera même
d'ici à 2024 la part des déplacements du
vélo dans les transports du quotidien
cela passe aussi par la création du
forfait mobilité durable pour inciter
les employés à utiliser le vélo ou le
covoiturage pour leur trajet du
quotidien ou encore par la réduction des
émissions des navires à quai au travers
du plan escale 0 fumée voilà monsieur le
sénateur c'est bien ce gouvernement qui
a proposé la mise en oeuvre de ces
mesures pour apporter une solution aux
conséquences dramatiques de la pollution
de l'air
monsieur le ministre sur la pollution de
l'air commission européenne cour de
justice conseil d'état trois cartons
jaunes vous êtes clairement hors jeu et
nous sommes à la veille d'avoir carton
rouge pour une condamnation financière
sur les mobilités au mois de juillet
vous avez décidé six mois après la
décision de la prime à la conversion de
changer les règles
honnêtement ça ne se fait pas et en plus
bas alors qu'on vient de décider d'une
nouvelle loi sur les mobiles
d'orientation sur la mobilité vous ne
permettez pas aux intercommunalités de
conduire leurs politiques en les
soutenant sur le crédit d'impôt
transition énergétique
vous venez de sortir pratiquement la
moitié des français du dispositif d'aidé
de soutien alors qu'il faut aujourd'hui
regardez la réussite de l'étiquette
énergétique
en face sur l'agriculture nos paysans
aujourd'hui de taille culture a besoin
d'être soutenue elle et dans la
transition écologique elle travaille
pour la réussite et la qualité
alimentaire alors qu effectivement plus
d'un tiers des agriculteurs n'ont pas
450 euros par mois
permettez leur un de les accompagner de
lutter contre la grille bashing et 3 et
enfin deux puissent vivre dignement de
leur travail
enfin je constate une chose c'est vous
passez votre temps à annoncer vous
voulez verdir votre politique mais vous
vous contentez en fait de la dernire
c'est trop peu merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]